stephen says he wants a plunge pool like
you have and he says he's serious he
wants you to promise him on the podcast
right now that you'll hook him up
all right stephen i'll kill for the
punch
i know the owner i i was really lucky i
saw this thing on online and i just
i was uh
during covey like during our quarantine
i was so bored and i was like i want to
talk to somebody who i'm like fast
nearby and wim hof was somebody who i
just i admire so much the i don't know
if you know anything about hockey he's
called me iceman and he basically
like
invented cold plunge therapy um and he
he basically he's broken numerous world
records he does not get sick they
injected him with e coli and his body
beat it and he's fascinating so i ended
up getting on like on on like a live um
instagram with him and started asking
all these questions and um i've always
loved the cold water it's like i just
feel like when you're in that much pain
and you're like you just you have to go
inwards and you have to kind of just
like breathe through it it's really how
cold how cold are we talking about here
you plunge when you plunge into this
water how cold is this water
yeah so like i'm trying to think in i
think my well freezing's 32 degrees
okay so like my my plunge pool is at
like 43 or 42. and how long can you stay
in this plunge pool
i did i did i did 15 minutes which was
way too long i did 15 minutes and then i
was just like shivering the whole day so
usually i try to do like five
five minutes um
or so you know it's just like an ice
bath you know after a workout or
something and you do this all the time
i try yeah i mean i tried it right now
it's yeah i had to i moved it onto this
like structure in the backyard so i got
to fill it back up again but yeah
usually i try to do it like every day or
every other day